Garth Brooks is too country music now
the guy's done it all well almost all
he's now busy notching another first in
his legendary career feel lucky to be
standing here and just want to represent
me Garth Brooks celebrating a little
something extra during his first concert
ever at the historic Ryman in Nashville
last night he just launched the Garth
channel on Sirius XM radio and we're
asking people come on take this ride
with us expect appearances wife Trisha
Yearwood I always want to do my best
around her because you know if you're
anywhere near her you're doing pretty
good and new music from the man himself
we've been in the studio we've got a you
actually here to do albums duets
Christmas elves and then the new fall
record but we also love glass we have to
find out what Garth thought about Ashton
Kutcher performing his hit friends in
low places with country star Thomas
Rhett in front of our cameras nearly two
weeks ago
they were fantastic I'd love to take a
shot at singing that with hypsi see if I
could doing any better than red or by
both of